c'est bon alors il en pense quoi votre
frère vous connaissez pas ce qu'il ya ça
ils d'eric et oui bien sûr la paix du
tour hier un peu magnifique bâtisse de
lyon à l'aller les grosses sa chevelure
vas-y crinière de feu c'est bon le beau
parleur a testé salamalecs b tun un peu
ton truc m'a brisé le coeur ce n'est pas
aux quotas mis le pied de leur bon je te
le dire on verra mort h et du mauvais
gars non content quand votre frère alors
voilà une bonne question qu'est ce que
c'est ils en pensent quoi votre frère
c'est simple on ne t'a vu des gens dans
la rue pendant qu'ils nous répondrons se
change on s'habille comme eux vous avez
vu ça mathieu pris l'eau il vous
connaissez ça non merci loïc vous savez
vous connaissez les personnes autour de
la femme
vous avez déjà regardé l'émission palau
et oui c'est vrai oui là c'est le
nouveau c'est parti
je trouve que c'est très très bien il ya
des métros des bus y en a pas mal
les horaires un peu moins mais ils sont
un peu bon des fois et votre frein il en
pense quoi
on ferait mais il y a quand même des
problèmes inhérents au fonctionnement de
ces transports et votre haine en bourse
quoi bon moi je suis plus souvent qu'à
mme larin sur par adam
mais bon c'est vrai que bon bah dès que
j'ai les clébards ou quoi ouais je suis
obligée de prendre les transports s'est
jamais y perd efficace quoique bien
parce que ça on est bien desservi par
mois et où est la rue
c'est incroyable la saga littéraire il
en pense quoi
qui peu la même chose pas c'est qu'on
est souvent blasé par les transports
principalement dans les annonces qui
sont toujours un cran possible au micro
et votre frère elle en pense quoi bon ma
femme mon épouse on va se faire beau
frère salut la compagnie je suis plutôt
satisfait et votre est il en pense quoi
ouais bah ouais tu un beau petit cul
mais oui tu as beau petit cul
hébras mois dans l'or qui s'occupe de
twitter aval à celle où qui est fabuleux
indre abeilles et dans tous les loups
qui ont un bravo et vous alors quelle
comédie la commedia dell' la pizza del
arte
c'est pour nous autres trucs